my name is Billy normally I'm from
McDonough Georgia and I'm a junior this
year my project is about keeping your
private information secure conventional
encryption solutions either our hardware
based or software based software based
ones have the problem that you've got to
install software on every single
computer you want to use your encrypted
hard drive on hardware encryption you've
got to buy new punch I've specialized
dried chives and throw out the old ones
mine device V is as old archives it
doesn't require any installation and
it's it uses my encryption algorithm
featuring a subliminal channel so you
can hide data in the archive so it can't
even be proven to exist we have our
computer here but right now it connects
to the RCC eve of MP over Ethernet the
Vicki shares the contents of the hard
drive unencrypted over a samba share
inside of the Vicki I run a line
external with the custom file system
module based on house too yeah the X to
the modified X to file system browse
user space programs to encrypt and
decrypt
Royals as they requested it then caches
the unencrypted file in ram so
subsequently tonight's are very fast
every couple of minutes who might the
file is closed the Mickey being encrypts
the new file and sends it back to the
disk if you just have the disk is
completely encrypted you cannot beat
anything off of the disk if you don't
have the mickey and the correct key